primero el problema
digamos que yo tengo la segunda derivada
de g
mi función y +4 por la función y todo
esto va a ser igual a seno de t seno de
t menos
la función escalón a unitario
en el punto 2 pie
x el seno
dt menos dos pies
vamos a resolver esta ecuación
diferencial y aquí creerme que podríamos
hacer una lista de vídeos sobre cómo
interpretar la realización o la
resolución de las ecuaciones
diferenciales pueden ver esto como una
función de fuerza media extraña en la
que mejor se aplica algún peso y este es
el término de la aceleración la segunda
derivada del tiempo normalmente esa
aceleración igual la masa podría ser 1 y
la función de la posición podría incluir
la constante de un resorte pero no nos
vamos a meter en eso no nos vamos a
meter en la interpretación de qué
significa esta función simplemente vamos
a resolverla más adelante habrá
oportunidad para todas las
interpretaciones bueno ahora vamos a
aplicar la transformada de la plaza en
ambos lados de esta ecuación así que
cuál es la transformada de la plaza del
lado izquierdo la tan sonada de la plaza
de la segunda derivada de g
s al cuadrado vamos a escribir sólo la
transformada de laplace de esta parte
ese cuadrado multiplicada por la
transformada de la planta y menos aquí
bajamos el grado a 1 - s x evaluada en 0
- de prima valuada en cero aquí les digo
quedaron las condiciones iniciales pues
para poder resolver esto apropiadamente
y agregamos además más 4 por la
transformada de la plaza de y que es
igual cuando es la transformada de la
plaza de seno de t
ahorita ustedes lo deberían de manejar
hasta dormidos
/ s cuadrada + 1
y después tenemos menos esta función
escalón unitario cuál es la transformada
de la plaza de esto voy a hacer una
anotación aquí a un lado para que nos
acordemos de cuál es la transformada de
la plazas de esta función es carl
humanitario
hace un par de vídeos vimos que la
transformada de la plaza
qué bueno yo creo que lo voy a escribir
aquí
esto va a ser lo mismo que escribí la
transformada de laplace de seno de t
pero tendremos que multiplicarlo por el
ala menos si recuerdan la última fórmula
multiplicarlo por el ala menos c donde
se es 2 pi lo mejor si vamos a
escribirlo aquí
más vale escribirlo explícitamente para
que quede todo perfectamente claro
la transformada de la plaza de la
función escalón unitario se ha
multiplicado por una función con un
desplazamiento de se va a ser igual a el
elevado hace por ese poblado sumada de
la plaza de la función original
la transformada de la plaza
efe dt así que aplicando la transformada
de la clase esto no está se va a ser dos
para nuestra gente va a ser seno de t
menos dos por ti
así que todo esto va a ser igual vamos a
escribirlo aquí
va a ser igual o al menos por ese 62
entonces es el ala menos dos por fin por
s
multiplicada por la transformada de la
plaza de fp que es seno de quitamos lo
del desplazamiento
así que la transforma de laplace decena
de t va a ser igual a 1 entre s cuadrada
más 1 ahora regresamos a nuestra
ecuación que estamos trabajando
y al realizar la transformada de la
presión ambos lados de la ecuación nos
quedan y no tenemos condiciones
iniciales aunque todavía no las escribo
pero el problema no los da
y las condiciones iniciales que nos
están dando las voy a escribir aquí en
el margen nos dicen en naranja
y de cero va a ser igual a cero
y el primer valuada en cero va a ser
igual a cero
lo que es genial porque esto nos
simplifica los cálculos esto va a ser
cero y esto va a ser cero
veamos si podemos simplificar esto
del lado izquierdo de la ecuación
agrupamos este término con este término
así que nos queda la transformada de la
plaza de y que multiplica a ese cuadrado
mas esto ese cuadrado más 4
cerramos que va a ser igual al lado
derecho
y este es uno podríamos simplificarlo
ahorita pero no quiero hacer muchos
pasos a la vez para no confundirlos
así que nos queda que es 1 en 13
cuadrada + 1
o bueno de hecho no es menos menos
al menos 2 por s / s cuadrada más 1
y ahora podemos escribir todo esto si
dividimos ambos lados de la ecuación
entre el término s cuadrada más 4 nos
queda la transformada de la plaza de y
que es igual y aquí de hecho podría
combinar estas dos estas dos fracciones
ya que tienen el mismo denominador antes
de que divide todo esto entre s cuadrada
+4 el lado derecho de la ecuación se
vería así con el mismo denominador es
cuadrada más 11
- y al menos dos por s
y cuando hacemos la división del s
cuadrada + 4 que dividimos ambos lados
de la ecuación por este término vamos a
multiplicar el denominador por s
cuadrada más 4 y ahora viene la parte
difícil para poder calcular que tenemos
que encontrar una función inversa de la
transformada de la plaza que se vea así
como encontramos la transformada inversa
de la plage de todo esto aunque resolver
esto es fácil si ustedes tienen en mente
todas las transformadas de la plaza
veamos si podemos hacer una expansión de
fracciones parciales veamos si podemos
reescribir esto
la podemos reescribir de esta manera ya
que así nos va a simplificar el trabajo
vamos a factorizar esto afuera 1 - al
menos 2 por ti por s y todo esto va a
multiplicar
a lo que voy a escribir a quien era la 1
/ s cuadrada + 1 x s cuadrada + 4
ahora vamos a hacer una expansión de
fracciones parciales veamos si podemos
reescribir esto
podemos escribir esta ecuación
hasta la derecha 1 entre ese cuadrado 1
por s cuadrada más 4
la podemos reescribir como dos
fracciones separadas una con s cuadrada
+ 1 de denominador y la otra con s
cuadrada + 4 como denominador y sus
numeradores deberían ser
a ese más b y desde otro lado tenemos cs
cuando sumamos estas dos cosas
debemos tener
s más b x s cuadrada más 4 más
c por s más de todo esto multiplicado
por s cuadrada más 1 todo esto entre
este denominador ese cuadrada más 1 por
s cuadrada más 4 normalmente estos
problemas de ecuaciones diferenciales
requieren de mucha energía hay que
decirse a sí mismo tengo que continuar y
resolver toda la región necesaria para
poder resolver este problema tienen que
emocionarse al respecto emocionarse al
ver que tenemos todavía está álgebra que
resolver
vamos a calcular esta parte de arriba
puede simplificarse como a s al cubo
+ b por s al cuadrado
4 x a por s
+ 4 por d
y esto
continuamos aquí abajo sepor es el cubo
más de pones al cuadrado
más se pone sé
+ d
vamos a sumar todos estos elementos
juntos este es todo el álgebra que
tenemos que hacer para bien o para mal a
más x s kubica
más bien más de multiplicar por ese
cuadrado más 4 am c x s nos hacemos un
poco a la derecha más 4 b más d y ahora
lo que tenemos que recordar es que todo
esto es igual a esto que está aquí
arriba simplemente hemos simplificado
numerador este es el numerador
y tengo esto va a ser el numerador de
ese cuadrada más 1 por s cuadrada más 4
y establecimos que todo esto deberá ser
debe ser igual a 1 / s cuadrado más 1 x
s cuadrada más 4 así que tenemos que
encontrar una coincidencia de patrones
en el coeficiente todo esto es una
expansión de ecuaciones parciales
además de ese coeficiente de ese cubica
y de este otro lado no tenemos nada con
ese término de ese cúbica
así que a más se va a ser igual a cero
vemos ve más de ese coeficiente de
nuestra y sea cuadrado en este otro lado
tampoco tenemos por lo que ve más de va
a ser igual a 0 4 a más es el
coeficiente de s aquí tampoco tenemos
ese así que cuatro ama se va a ser igual
a cero y lo único que nos queda 4 b más
de va a ser igual a 14 b más de igual a
1 vamos a ver cómo podemos encontrar la
solución menos 3 a que es igual a 0 a es
igual a cero si lo vemos de esta parte y
se va a ser igual a cero
restamos esto de esto otro
-3 ven esto se cancela
esto es igual a menos 1 b va a ser igual
a un tercio
por lo que ve es igual a menos de eso
los sacamos d es igual a un tercio
así que todo este trabajo nos da un
resultado bastante simple vamos a
regresar a nuestro espacio por acá
ahora vamos a reescribir nuestra
ecuación
un tercio entre s cuadrada más uno
es el coeficiente y esto vamos a dejarlo
muy claro que es el término que está
encima de ese cuadrado más uno
y b es menos de permítanme aclarar esto
es igual a un tercio
vamos a revisar que esté bien
ve es un tercio
de es menos un tercio
ves el término que está encima de ese
cuadrado más uno
y tenemos menos de menos un tercio entre
s cuadrada 4
como les dije esto necesita de mucha
energía y mucha paciencia
bueno ahora vamos a reescribir todo esto
para que podamos regresar a nuestro
problema principal pues ya que cuando
nos involucramos en esta expansión de
fracciones parciales como que nos
olvidamos de por qué lo hicimos en
primer lugar así que tenemos la
transformada de la plaza de iu que es
igual
1 - y al menos dos por pi por s x todo
esto que desarrollamos hace un momento
por un tercio x 1
entre ese cuadrado 1
- un tercio multiplicado
y de hecho permíteme escribirlo de otra
manera para que quede un poquito más
claro
quiero tener un 2 en el numerador así
que va a ser 2 entre s cuadrada más 4
si hago esto de poner el 2 en el
numerador pues tengo que poner aquí en
el denominador algo que me lo neutraliza
así que va a ser un 6
menos un sexto por dos entre ese
cuadrado más cuatro eso lo sé poniendo
la forma más parecida a la transformada
de la plaza de seno de t
ahora vamos a ver si hay algo que yo
pueda hacer para resolver esto ya que es
un problema épico realmente
y realmente me sorprendería si no me
equivocara a realizar esto así que
podemos reescribir todo esto y vamos a
ver si lo podemos simplificar un poco
más
aunque a simplificar no lo voy a hacer
un poquito más largo podemos escribir la
transformada de la plaza de iu que es
igual
primero voy a multiplicar el 1 por todo
lo demás y luego el menos al menos 2 y
por eso se multiplica primero el 1 voy a
tener
un tercio multiplicado uno entre ese
cuadrado más uno menos un sexto
x 2 / s cuadrada más 4 y ahora voy a
multiplicar por el menos
al menos 2 por mí por s
aquí lo voy a hacer en otro color aquí
tengo menos a la menos dos por pi por s
entre 3 x 1 / s cuadrada más 1 - por
menos es más así que ahora tengo más a
la menos 2 party por s / 6 x 2 / s
cuadrada más 4
ahora tratemos de encontrar una
transformada de la plaza inversa que sea
igual a esto bueno pues ya lo tenemos
bastante directo
y nos quedan ye igual le ha transformado
de la classe inversa de esto va a ser un
tercio de seno de t
seno de t
y eso es menos un sexto
un sexto
seno de 2 t
por eso es que quise poner el 2 arriba
en este número 2 y todas estas son casi
lo mismo pero tenemos este término de al
menos 2 picores y aquí tenemos que
acordarnos que la transformada de la
plaza
lo voy a escribir aquí abajo la
transformada de la plaza
de la función escalón unitario
de dos pies
x s dt menos 2 por fin
esto va a ser igual
y al menos dos por people s x la
transformada de la plaza de esto con una
f
perdón déjenme corregir esto
multiplicado por la conformada de
laplace
si suponemos que el frente es seno de 2
por t y nos damos cuenta que tenemos que
desplazarlo y multiplicarlo por al menos
2 people s que es la función escalón
unitario y quiero que quede esto claro
si sólo tuviéramos este término la
transformada de la plaza inversa de esto
sería la misma que esta otra seno de t
la transformada de la plaza inversa de
esto sería seno de 2 t pero tenemos
estos términos que esencialmente en
lugar de tener nuestra transformada de
la plaza inversa de ft va a ser nuestra
efe dt pero desplazada por dos pi
iba a estar multiplicada por nuestra
función escalón unitario en dos pi
así que esto va a hacer
menos
tercio x la función escalón unitario de
dos pin
dt
x en lugar del seno de te va a ser el
seno de t menos 2 y ya casi terminamos
vamos a hacer la última parte en magenta
para celebrar
es nuestro último término un sexto
multiplicado por la función escalón
unitario en dos ping de t
multiplicado por el seno
y aquí tenemos que tener cuidado en
lugar de poner esto como late -2 pin a
quien va a ser seno de dos porte menos
dos pie
aquí ya está
por fin hemos podido resolver nuestra
ecuación diferencial bastante densa
usando la transformada de la plaza
podrían formarse a un tiempo si ustedes
quisieran para simplificar esto todavía
se puede reducir un poco más y yo creo
que de hecho lo vamos a hacer aún a
riesgo de que me pueda equivocar en el
último momento vamos a ver si podemos
hacer alguna simplificación aquí de
hecho no se ve algo obvio que podamos
simplificar podríamos factorizar esto de
aquí pero al parecer esto es lo más
simple a lo que podemos llegar así que
esta es nuestra función de t que
satisface a nuestra aparentemente simple
ecuación diferencial que teníamos aquí
arriba que parecía muy directa pero
terminamos con todo este desastre para
encontrar esta función que satisface
esta ecuación diferencial con las
condiciones iniciales que tenemos